this is an 8 news now breaking news  alert  let's get you back to our breaking news  two people are shot one is dead in north  las vegas it happened near carrie and  martin luther king earlier this  afternoon 8 news now reporter madison  kimbrough just arrived there and has an  update for us madison  north las vegas police department  confirmed that a shooting took place  here on helen avenue that was just  before 2 p-m this afternoon police say a  man and a woman both in their 20's were  shot it's still unclear what led up to  the shooting but medics took them both  to the hospital the man later died and  the woman is in stable condition  according to police this is not believed  to be a random act of violence anyone  with information is asked to contact the  north las vegas police department  immediately we will bring you the latest  coming up at six o'clock as well  reporting live madison kimbrough live  local now